to all you tabloids out there you have
been with my life since I was 13 years
old it's Drew Barrymore versus the
tabloids I have never said that I wish
my mother was dead in a cover story for
New York Magazine Drew spoke candidly
about the tumultuous relationship with
her mother Jay Barrymore who served as
her manager when Drew was a child in the
article Drew says she's sometimes
jealous of other former child stars
whose parents have died quote all their
moms are gone and my mom's not and I'm
like well I don't have that luxury but I
cannot wait this comment quickly made
headlines and Drew is clapping back on
Instagram I have been vulnerable and
tried to figure out a very difficult
painful relationship while admitting it
is difficult to do while a parent is
alive and that for those of us who have
to figure that out in real time cannot
wait as in they cannot wait for the time
not that the parent is dead Drew has
been very open about their complicated
mother-daughter Dynamic having been
emancipated from her parents since the
age of 14. however Drew says she would
never wish her mom ill will don't twist
my words around or ever say that I wish
my mother was dead I have never said
that I never would in fact I go on to
say that I wish that I never have to
live in existence where I would wish
that on someone because that is sick